foreign
[Music]
shootout on the streets of the Bronx
tonight a 51 year old grandfather shot
dead in broad daylight
I've seen plenty of violence in my
career but a professional hit like this
caught my attention
The Killing was allegedly part of an
ongoing Turf War but not between rival
street gangs or Mafia Prime families
these men were from rival motorcycle
clubs
that one percenter patch is declaring 99
of everybody else law-abiding citizens
we are the one percent that are the
criminals
to wear that as a badge of honor
some people might judge us the symbols
that we wear and if that makes ourselves
I was so be it
these clubs are a contradiction on two
wheels
proudly and loudly public on American
roads
and yet notoriously Secret
membership truly entails you live
outside the law
[Music]
use that one percent
what's motivating the violence
who's calling the shots
and what does it really mean
in the one percent
thank you
[Music]
within the biker World certain
motorcycle clubs have a reputation for
violence and secrecy
the vagos are one of those clubs
traditionally our club has been one of
the most tight-lipped of them all
but I am a fan of opening people's eyes
[Music]
president
and then they called here we go Bigfoot
I started riding Harley Davidsons in my
mid-20s and it didn't take long to
discover that these one percenter clubs
dictate the life and I wanted to have a
say
term one percenter comes from the
Trump claims that 99 of bikers are law
abiding citizens
implication proudly embraced by certain
clubs like the Vagas is that the other
one percent live by their own rules
we say to the world we understand what
American written law is but we believe
some of it to be
[Applause]
if you say something horrible to me the
law says I'm not allowed to punch you in
the mouth for it
we say we can
we accept whatever punishment comes with
that and let me tell you this
well eight cops
but what we don't like are the the dirty
portion of them
who like to stand before a group of
mainstream media press and then they
like to call us the mafia on two wheels
they call you games right yeah
I love to use that word gang gang gang
why is it that there's so much
animosity between different clubs
I wouldn't say that there is
so you guys are best friends with all
the other clubs I wouldn't say that
either our club motto is we give what we
get
and sometimes it results in some really
rough stuff what about murder
what about it
that you guys have been involved in
murder
well every once in a while a melee
between a couple of guys or a couple of
clubs go at it
maybe maybe a guy dies
when we go into this life we know that
that is something that could happen
members of the vagos motorcycle gang
were armed the vagos have a bloody
history they are an immediate threat to
the public safety but it's hard to get
to get drug trafficking it's false and
that's not not something you've ever
witnessed or saw or you do not condone
that as far as
the vagos motorcycle club being some
amazingly disorganized yet organized
drug Empire forget about it not a chance
I mean of course I'm on film I wouldn't
say it if we were but I mean it's
utterly ridiculous
I don't know what every single guy does
for a living and I have no doubt that
there might be a couple of guys that are
up to no good I don't judge my brothers
that's their business
Bigfoot wants me to believe in What's
called the Bad Apple defense
[Music]
the idea that the entire Club isn't
Criminal
just a few bad apples
I'm suspicious but I just don't know
enough to know if he's telling me the
truth
I need to better understand these bikers
I need two good stitches
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
for 10 days every August the Tiny Town
of Sturgis South Dakota gets a little
louder
[Music]
that's what happens when the city of
seven thousand people plays host to half
a million most of them
[Music]
everybody it's all walks of lives we
have doctors and attorneys that are here
you have people that are homeless here
and everybody in between
[Music]
but there is a darker sun to the Sturgis
Motorcycle Rally
and why Shane comes too
14 years running
apartment
he's one of the more than a hundred law
enforcement agents brought in from other
cities to patrol the event over the
years Sturgis has seen plenty of
violence it's really intense man they're
going in at the Mongols and the Hell's
Angels
I've witnessed the shooting
witnessed and then your basic salts
Shane says most of the trouble
originates with one percenters we refer
to him as omglr motorcycle gains laws
don't apply to them so you don't think
they're afraid of law enforcement at all
you know if they want to do something
they're going to do it as a journalist
if I'm trying to get into these clubs
and see how they operate do you think
that's an easy thing to do
I would say no I would say good luck
I hit the streets of Sturgis eager to
find another way in
what's strange about this story
especially compared to other
investigations I've done is that these
one percenters aren't hard to find
they literally wear their allegiances on
their backs
but that doesn't mean they want to talk
these one percenter clubs are so
secretive that some of them don't even
stay in Sturgis
they stay outside of town at private
campgrounds that apparently get wild
searching for an invite I reach out to a
biker turned radio host named Hollywood
why here is popular with the one
presenters and welcome to this
additional motorcycle mad house radio
thanks for joining us
[Music]
Hollywood hi Hollywood it's Marianna how
are you doing it's a long shot but I ask
if you can get me inside one of these
campgrounds
to my surprise
he comes through
that's where I'm heading now to meet a
one percenter club called the Sons of
Silence the suns are a real deal
push back
they lived this life
I take it to the edge and drive off
why do you think they agreed to speak to
Usman
because I asked them
so when I see the girl out in the gate
I'll ask you guys to put the cameras
down
which I think is here actually so
cameras down we're here we're here
I have no idea what we're walking into
thank you
[Music]
this goes well
there's a steady drum beat of violence
within biker culture
my quest to understand why has led me to
the private Campground of a one
percenter club called the Sons of
Silence
it's like something out of Mad Max
but our invite has come with some
restrictions
we can quote Swatch but not engage
[Music]
this is crazy
no members can speak on camera without
permission from the leaders
so I'm stuck
just looking at these men
these faces
[Music]
I find myself thinking about the faces
of their brothers the ones I've seen in
mug shots Federal authorities indicted
members of the Sons of Silence
motorcycle gang an illegal narcotics
Trafficking Organization
12 years club members have been
convicted of
going math
and go sex trafficking
extortion assault abduction and murder
that rap sheet is front of Mind as I
tore the grounds with our minder a biker
named Cody who wears an enforcer patch
do most members come it's a mandatory
run so everybody comes it's mandatory to
come oh I didn't know that
apparently I'm not
what's this every chapter has a flag and
when they get here they hanging on the
flag
you raise it up
how many are supposed to be here do you
know
I do
that's where the silence part comes in
how often is it that you have cameras
don't make pizza phones never
at all
okay I'm game yeah yeah it's your show
let's go
the only members we're allowed to
interview are Cody and a man named boar
who's been in the club nearly 50 years
but even our interview has strict rules
attached
um so I'm going to ask you the questions
that we've agreed upon I'd say it's the
first time that I have a list of
questions in front of me because I
usually like it to be more of a
conversation but we've agreed upon these
questions and I believe you have answers
in front of you
um so first question is what attracts
people to motorcycle clubs a lot of
people are attracted here due to the
freedom and the love of riding
motorcycles
the Brotherhood and the sense of the
family and belonging to something bigger
than yourself
what makes this Brotherhood different
than just regular friends
a lot of these guys we have in our club
are veterans of every war you can think
of
[Music]
when I came around 46 years ago it was
all Vietnam veterans when they came home
from what they ever did elsewhere
they were soldiers to go home and be
happy you're home many of these
returning soldiers struggled to adjust
especially in the face of a protest
movement that often blamed them for the
failures and atrocities of the war
seeking the camaraderie they'd known
while serving many were drawn to these
civilian bands of Brothers
it's freedom for me what's real ain't
plastic
the side is grouping
my
[Music]
some of the veterans
have had their fellow people but here
they feel like they're at home
this is where everybody's accepted if
this is where you want to be
and that's what this was all about
the military's influence is telling
on the surface the scene feels wild and
freewheeling but there's a structure
that Lies Beneath
the mandatory attendance
the flag displays the organized
competitions
they wear a different kind of uniform
but they're still trained to obey their
leaders in our club it takes at least a
year to be a full patch holder
members must undergo a
vet Prospect as they're known prove
their commitment to the club by
following members orders
it's not hard to spot these prospects
around Camp I see one tending the fire
another one on his bike they can only
wear What's called the bottom rocker ID
in their chapter only once accepted they
become full patch members and earn their
colors the club's logo
if they're not satisfactory to what
we're looking for we get rid of them
can I ask you though the tattoos and the
meanings of the tattoos and the patches
okay the SS which you know is the elite
team of the Nazis
right
or does SS represent something else for
you
for me it does
I'm not going to talk about it
Rudy may deny it the charges of racism
and sexism
dogged these one percenter clubs through
the years
if you remember you'd understand some
tattoos are to keep people away
and don't ask
does that make sense absolutely
I won't last ask about the tattoos
anymore of them I didn't hear you I
won't ask about the tattoos anymore then
thank you but I also stay on Scripts
what what exactly is an Outlaw Biker
what does that mean
that one I don't think is a good
question
the police are the ones that have
deedness to be Outlaws
this is who we are what we are and what
we do
I think they're trying to portray us as
something we
we're not
and and it's it it is working because
[Music]
coming here I wasn't sure what to expect
is that something that you want to
continue is that something that you're
hoping will change your image to the
outside world what people think about us
right but you also don't want people to
think that you're criminals we really
don't care
we're not here to be anything to anybody
we're here for us
is it possible that these one percenters
just have an image problem
that they aren't really Outlaws just
outcasts wanting to be left alone
unsure I head back to LA
where I connect with a new source a
biker who says he's willing to open up
about how these clubs really operate
from the inside
that one percenter patch that you see on
my vest here they wear that as a badge
declaring hate we are a gang we are a
criminal organization
they know what it means
the culture knows what it means
but they're not going to say that
they're going to call themselves a club
we're a motorcycle club we just like to
do what we do because it's the freedom
of the riding they're going to distance
themselves from any opportunity
to say that they're an actual gang
how many clubs have
clubs personally I've infiltrated three
separate motorcycle gangs and each one
of them becoming a full patch member in
all three
and all three you became a full-fatch
member yes that's right this dude is a
federal agent and within law enforcement
circles a legend
his name is Darren Kozlowski better
known as cause
between
1997 and 2008 I was undercover a
full-time
for approximately six of those 11 years
in those three games
cause explains that these clubs have
sold the public a story
the same story that the Sons of Silence
and Bigfoot try to sell me
but the reality
is much dirtier
and he's lived it
as Undercovers we are thinking the worst
people have been killed even being
suspected of being informants or
snitches for these kind of gangs and
there's been murders for people even
thinking that they were informants and
they even weren't
Darren Koslowski lived with that fear
for years
as an undercover agent with the ATF the
Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
he infiltrated three of the most
notorious one percenter motorcycle clubs
the vagos warlocks and Mongols they'll
make money for many means necessary
they're opportunists so if it's the drug
game weapons if it's prostitution
they'll find a way to do it and on top
of that you'll have the other events
that come along with it the violence the
fighting the stabbings the territorial
disputes the murders cause explains
makes them effective as criminal gangs
it gives them that means to conduct
their business
with that level of trust that separates
them a little bit differently from
everybody else and then when they're
getting some heat from another rival
gang yeah they can make a phone call to
LA and La is going to send 100 dudes to
that area and that's going to be
followed with
intimidation going into bars acts of
violence stabbings beatings whatever it
may be to establish themselves to a
point of dominance that we're not here
to be with
cost tells me the Bronx killing was the
result of a classic Turf rivalry the
pagans were unhappy that the Hell's
Angels had moved their Clubhouse into
the Bronx
the beef escalated
the Pagan leader was gunned down
because in their culture that patch
means so much that that gang means so
much to them
that's what they live and die over
weeks later cause tips me off to a one
percenter's funeral
a member of the Mongols Motorcycle Club
has died and brothers are gathering for
a tradition called The Last Ride
wow you can see all the bikes already up
there yeah where do you see the
procession there's there'll be four or
500 bikes yeah it's even impressive for
us and we've been working it forever but
there's something else that makes this
funeral different
it's being monitored by the feds
they know that we're out here it isn't
like a covert stealthy thing that you
know creates a perception in their mind
that we're still working now
waiting for them to slip up
special agent John Ciccone leads atf's
investigations into one percenter clubs
in Southern California
during causes years undercover he
considered chiconi his Guardian Angel so
what's going to happen is you're going
to have your road captains right
which are these guys and their their job
is to block off intersections
as this thing proceeds so it keeps the
whole pack together are they allowed to
do this to block the roads no but who's
going to stop you're not gonna get
yourself in the middle of all that just
because it's a run a red light you know
what I mean
the bikers fall into formation again I
sense the military's influence
The Last Ride is a show of respect
it's also a very public display of force
oh wow so that's the hearse right here
yeah and then you got one guy protecting
it one Rider then it's just a sea of
bikes behind
looking at us yeah it's gonna get dicey
I mean the whole car is faking
see that he flipped a middle finger
right off yeah
I'm truly like my my body just need a
rest right now sometimes
I primarily worked the Mongol so I know
the most about them
they want instill fear and intimidation
wherever they go
I consider them one of the most violent
out there
over the years atf's work has led to
several major takedowns homicides
narcotics some extremely violent
individuals who are taken off the street
today
speaking before a treasure Trove of
seized assets from the gang the U.S
attorney announced a major sweep and
takedown of the Mongols he called them a
violent criminal Enterprise
we convicted the gang we had four agents
that were members for three years
I mean they went through the process
hang around prospecting and then Full
Pass membership for that time period but
you know the protocols were broken down
to them
you know if you see in Hell's Angel
shoot on site
the Mongols have killed three Hells
Angels in the last month no way there's
a shooting here and then
Denver was a murder Indiana murder
Cleveland Ohio murder
so there's a huge fight going on between
the two yeah
it's been that way since the 70s
agent Ciccone shows me the video of a
massive brawl inside a Nevada Casino
[Music]
two Hells Angels died from gunshots
was stabbed to death
three thousand innocent civilians in
that casino
they didn't give her and the Hell's
Angel didn't give it they came in and
got it on
they got it on because they're that's
what gang members do
chiconi explains how the clubs encourage
these rivalries if you confront another
rival gang member you get a respect
future and unpatch you know it's a badge
of honor if you're involved in a
shooting
or a murder
you get a skull and crossbones patch
so they're promoting
the violence and rewarding the violence
giving them patches of course
been right there in front of my face
time
stitched into the leather coded language
that speaks to what these clubs value
you could put all the fluff around the
Harleys and all that but it's a gang
we all know what comes with that
violence
drug trafficking Farms trafficking
assaults murders shootings and they
operate just like a street gang they
just ride bikes
we got some information that a group of
Mongols is at a restaurant over here in
Monrovia so we're just going to kind of
go see what they're up to and then we'll
see if we can make contact with them so
by contact you mean just like try to
talk to a few of them
yeah we'll just pull up and and kind of
sit there with my windows down and see
if I can stir up anything
just just load steering oh yeah
Mexican restaurant
oh yeah there's some bikes
so there's definitely some numbers here
so they leave their helmets
[Music]
how much they're not afraid that
somebody
was with no planning and no backup agent
chaconi is about to roll up on one of
the most feared motorcycle clubs on the
planet
and the Mongols all know he's a federal
agent
so yeah this looks like the uh where
they're at
[Music]
what's going on
the Mongols motto is respect you
fear none
the ATF have called them the most
violent motorcycle club in the country
and yet agent John Ciccone has decided
it's a good idea to crash their
post-funeral lunch
what's going on
sure man
I thought that was you I'm like I had to
do a double take man
when agent chaconi invited me along for
this ride I didn't anticipate a friendly
chat with the infamous Mongols
I didn't know you're with the wife
not this time
and this isn't just any Mongol it's one
of the top leaders of the club
how'd the funeral go you guys make you
run and all that yeah yeah how was it we
seen you on the freeway yeah
we stay off the freeways next weekend
man because
castiglione's getting buried in the
Hell's Angel in San Diego oh yeah it was
like a 50-year member man oh yeah so
next weekend next weekend I heard they
buried three other dudes like in the
last month I don't know why but that's
what I hear that's no comment man yeah
no comments
no comment man
did you catch that score line
three zero
presumably meaning three Hells Angels
dead
zero Mongol skills investigators say
multiple people riding motorcycles were
involved in the shooting police were
saying the first one was stabbed to
death initial details painted the Fatal
confrontation between the rival gangs is
an argument that escalated
all right I'll let you guys go man wait
wait wait can I ask a question since
we're at this so we're with National
Geography I thought that was your wife
can we come hang out with you guys one
day yeah yeah yeah
I'm Mariana by the way Hi how are you
hello
don't record the number so I'm Mariana
I'll call you all right cool and then
I'm hoping we can hang out with you yeah
I can't promise anything but we'll talk
okay later thanks guys have a margarita
for us
oh my God
there you go man see what kind of hookup
you guys got here today but that was
that yeah the guy in the white shirt and
he immediately obviously knew who you
were and he jumped off the chair you
have to understand that we have an open
communication him and I
it's a respect thing that's all I can
really explain it
I've worked these guys since 97. you
don't harass them or disrespect them
but we we work them and we put the
criminals in jail especially with he's a
national president you know everything's
under his watch he doesn't want to go to
prison
but then there's times where he comes
more involved with being the national
president as you know giving out those
Awards and those patches when people do
stuff you know he's behind that
so there's absolutely no doubt in your
mind that they perform illegal
activities that they're criminals who
they are
not all of them commit crimes every day
or have criminal histories but
they have protocols that everybody has
to adhere to
forced into their criminal element when
you become a member all they have to do
is just act right and we would leave
them alone you know but as long as
they're going to keep shooting and
killing people then we're going to be
around
I want to know what role these leaders
actually play and if these clubs are
criminal Enterprises hiding in plain
sight then what's bringing in the money
I would say the drugs make the most
money for them cause tells me something
that I didn't know before
that the drugs they famously transport
are supplied and controlled by the
Mexican cartels
so if the cartels have such a network
here in the US already established why
work with the clubs to transport those
drugs what's in it for them I think it's
just going to come down to Pure business
if you have a gang that can move x
amount of weight
and you have a trusted member who can
deliver
from that connection
you now have a whole nother network of
people to distribute to you expand that
territory you've reached another group
that has that crossover connection with
cartel types
this is pure business
to see the criminal side of these one
percenters I've got to follow the money
and find a connection between the clubs
and the cartels and what about is there
do you have any connections outside of
California yeah it comes from Mexico too
over the years I've made underworld
contacts
on both sides of the Border okay
I've networked
estamos
[Music]
and in moments like this
I know who can open doors
[Music]
I just got the call we just got the call
yes they finally told us where to meet
it's a place where they feel safe it'll
be a place where we can sit and talk and
negotiate
if they know your name and they're
expecting your call they'll send a pin
of where we're supposed to meet them
finally after weeks of hustling a cartel
contact agrees to connect me to a one
percenter who transports narcotics
sure we're not being followed
okay I had two cameras down yes
more important than we that we not spook
them right now then
they want us to jump into their cars
yeah I don't think that's a good idea at
all I don't feel comfortable jumping in
the car with somebody that we don't know
and where they're taking those and all
that I don't think that's a good idea
they should be around here somewhere
get any updates well I'll call uh can we
not talk on the can we not put the
walkie-talkies up when we're caught
talking guys it's like if you want to
scream undercover cops that's it
I'm obviously paranoid at this point
okay so that's done guys leave the car
running
you look
Hi how are you doing Mariana
thank you
okay I'm gonna need you to put your own
other phones in the back turn them off
and do them on the car and leave them in
the other car so we can't take phones
with them can I take mine at least I can
shut it off
so a little bit of a problem is that
they don't want uh any of us take our
phones so they've asked that we keep our
phones here which makes me a little
nervous that's not a situation like to
be in at all
everybody smells are you okay
okay thanks guys
I'm in a car with a man I'm told is a
cartel operative
I presume is armed he's taking me to
meet a one percenter
but I don't know where we're going
or what we'll learn when we get there
[Music]
so you're not actually the person we're
going to be talking to right somebody
else
[Music]
all right this is him
so he was waiting here for us the whole
time this is apparently the biker in
question and he's clearly been tracking
our movements so do you work with the
cartel
sorry as a journalist I start asking
questions immediately
[Music]
oh it's a sort of a ranch house yeah
yeah
Wanna Be Me
one of many you guys have around here
yes
good guys
we arrive at a normal looking Ranch
House on a bit of land
as I get out of the car I met by a
masked man with a semi-automatic rifle
he directs me around the back of the
house and that's where I find our biker
for his safety we're covering his face
and changing his voice okay
what are you undecided about talking to
us I was yeah I don't really trust
nobody
did you check our work or did you check
me out to make sure that I wasn't police
oh yeah on you guys you did all of this
there's a network
bikers trust me any information that we
need from anybody is there
[Music]
can I ask you what club you belong to
you could ask me all day but I'm not
gonna say
but it's would you say that it's well
known one oh yeah it's a well-known one
yeah I I was told that you were part of
again I don't want to say you know I
can't expose myself because
this is a serious business
what would happen if they found out that
you were talking to me
I will Pride YouTube
they'll hurt you nor hurts when they
have to
they are you everybody
every last one of them
do you carry a gun with you all the time
you have it right now
so you still don't trust me
I don't trust nobody why did you agree
to do the center View and I'm going to
give you a big gun back of course
do
so what would you say then is the major
business of the club that you're that
you belong to yeah
finally after months of trying I find a
biker who's willing to talk about what
no other one percenter would
the criminal side of motorcycle clubs
what what drugs are we talking about oh
very different from weed cocaine glass
heroin
name it do it all
there's a bunch of bunch of guys that
just love to ride and want to be part of
the club
and there's others like myself that love
to get money and love that life and
that's what we do how much money do you
make
a lot
I push for details about their operation
and how they work with the Mexican
cartels
it's a sort of a working farm here yes
this is where we started
property is both a marijuana grow and a
stash house for whatever else might pass
through
this man oversees the operation for his
cartel bosses South of the Border
these are getting ready to be harvested
yes three more weeks three more weeks
yes
[Music]
so you work with these guys a lot
and yeah
myself and my people
they do the production side and you guys
do the transporting
digital world's packet
before we trim it
overweighted wow smell is super super
strong here so this is the flower that's
been harvested already yes
it smells good
I don't think most people know that you
guys are running an operation like this
just right here out in Southern
California this is just us but there's a
lot more
you'll be surprised
I got a network of guys that get the
merchandise from from these gentlemen
and we distribute it throughout the US
where do these drugs go to usually most
people in the street a lot of those are
two different states
further the more expensive it is
gloves everywhere
why do you guys like to work with the
bikers
they're not afraid of course you know
Dave ruthless pretty much
yes
even the Mexican
one percenters are ruthless does the
club leaders know that you do this and
that the members go up to this do they
make a cut out of it of course yeah do
they make good money
Everybody Eats
they're shot callers and there's people
underneath
they move other people in
so on and so on that's how you take care
of your family and live a good life
even if everything is doing this dirty
[Music]
does make sense
tight-lipped road trip loving American
Outlaws with local chapters
crisscrossing a country that spends
nearly 150 billion dollars a year on
illegal drugs
oh
I'm not saying every one percenter is
involved but wherever serious cash is
being made serious Trouble Follows why
is there so much hatred between clubs at
least it goes deep it goes deep
the territory thing I mean the fact that
you're assuming that you're controlling
the trafficking happening in this area
it's all about territory that's all it
is
[Music]
to go to war meaning you'd have to kill
other people you would do that whatever
it takes
a lot of organizations in the criminal
world don't advertise in the open who
they are motorcycle gangs do even a part
of me felt empowered when I got fully
patched
you get that sense that you have power
most Outlaws I've met live in the
shadows
but not these guys
they're bold enough to tell us exactly
who they are
endurance
to do something about it it's just
dangerous
you could die at any given time for any
given reason
do you think you'll continue doing it
I've been doing it in my life
until I'm late in the casket
[Music]